a o
[Música]
bom esse sou eu com cinco anos de idade
batendo as asas com essa fantasia
ridícula de pitimbu amarelinho e eu
tinha uma certeza eu tinha uma certeza
que eu ia conseguir voar
vocês não têm idéia de meca o passado
esse tempo todo e ainda continuo com
essa certeza de que eu ia voar e além do
mais eu já naquela época eu já gostava
muito de ler e não entender um pouquinho
porque eu sabia que se eu corresse
battisti a minha asa o máximo que eu
pudesse o mais rápido que eu pudesse eu
conseguiria correr correr correr atingir
a velocidade da luz e ali eu ia
conseguir viajar no tempo e no espaço e
é por isso que eu estou aqui hoje porque
eu consegui criar a máquina do tempo e
claro quem cria a máquina do tempo viaja
no tempo e no espaço ganhou o prêmio
nobel é por isso que estou aqui hoje que
deve tá todo mundo espantado né o tt
dexta chamado maluco né pra falar e fim
de que esse cara vai falar aqui pra
gente
bom eu tinha esse sonho e esse sonho de
viajar no tempo e no espaço
eu já gostava muito de literatura mas eu
achava que para viajar no tempo e no
espaço eu tinha que me dedicar à
engenharia matemática enfim eu me lembro
no dia que eu cheguei na escola né
aquela escola quando todo mundo é
pequenininho que tem que falar a
profissão que vai ser quando crescer não
é isso aí todo mundo né os coleguinhas
viram e falou você é engenheiro você
advogado
eu você médico né eu me lembro que eu
isto fez meu peito já tinha certeza do
que eu ia ser quando crescer
e aí virei e falei pra todo mundo
naquele dia naquela sala é que eu seria
astrofísico obviamente não sabe o que é
um astrofísico né
mas eu me lembro que eu lia já aquelas
coisas do einstein eu sabia que o
einstein ele era um astrofísico e eu
sabia que a existente ganhado o prêmio
nobel era isso que eu tinha para fazer
e era isso que eu queria fazer da vida
bom mas vocês devem imaginar que uma
criança será de 56 anos que chega na
sala de aula e fala pra todo mundo que
vai ser a astrofísica que vai acontecer
com essa criança bullying na certa né
então todo mundo naquele dia
é passou que vamos fazer um bullying com
jacques e o pior de tudo pior de tudo
aqui
com 56 anos eu queria que vocês lembrar
sem esses momentos com 56 anos de idade
todo mundo tem um namoradinho uma
namoradinha né
só que é aquele namoradinha namoradinha
que você não tem a menor coragem nem de
dirigir a palavra é isso você tem no seu
namorado e eu tinha minha silvinha silva
era minha paixão minha música infantil
eu era apaixonada com ele aquele dia
naquele dia em diante nunca mais olhou
pra mim claro imagina um cara que se
veste de pintinho amarelinho bate as
asas com toda força aquele que ele tem
ele ainda vive fala que o excesso do
físico
obviamente ela nunca mais quis nada
comigo
e esse momento ficou marcado ficou
marcada na história
bom eu continue nessa escola uma escola
bem pequenininha judaica e depois minha
mãe sabendo dos sonhos visionários que
eu tinha e mudou para uma outra escola
que era muito boa em física e matemática
bom eu tinha esse meu sonho certo de
descer em fim de criar máquina do tempo
ganhar o prêmio nobel eu falei para
vocês que eu conseguir
vocês vão ver e eu comecei a estudar
muito enfim
terminei o colégio foi fazer um moderado
ação ea graduação a única graduação que
eu imaginava que eu podia fazer
engenharia
eu fui fazer engenharia elétrica enfim
comecei minha vida estudando a cheia no
começo eu estava muito empolgado mas
depois achei aqui uma coisa muito chata
primeiro que eu tinha já uma certa
sensibilidade para a literatura poesia
coisa que eu acho que os engenheiros de
uma forma geral tentam esconder isso né
acho que todos têm mas eles escondem
segundo que estava pronto para me
inscrever uma disciplina que chamasse né
é viagem no tempo e o prêmio nobel e não
tinha essa disciplina sendo ofertada né
e aí eu comecei a ficar muito triste no
curso de engenharia fiquei um tempo
deprimido
só que eu gostava muito dos fundamentos
da matemática dos fundamentos da física
e eu pensei comigo bom se eu conseguir
criar a teoria toda a viagem do tempo já
já tá bom né um outro engenheiro vai lá
e e constrói pra mim eu não preciso
criar né
gostava muito de um professor de
matemática esses professores na nossa
vida e nos estimulam é nos mostram o
caminho enfim eu acabei largando em
engenharia elétrica e mudando para a
matemática a matemática mudei todo feliz
e acho que todo mundo aqui já viu sessão
da tarde não já aquele programa noite
passa a tarde na que a gente tá
enrolando né procrastinando que deveria
fazer a gente ficar assistindo à sessão
da tarde na sessão da tarde todo mundo
conhece aquele é curso de verão férias
de verão né
eu fui fazer o meu curso de verão e as
férias de verão lá no inpa instituto de
matemática pura e aplicada e achei que
eu ia ficar lá no rio de janeiro tomando
sol passe ano aproveitando eu cheguei lá
é o lugar mais difícil de uma temática
talvez do mundo em sistemas dinâmicos né
pra vocês terem uma idéia três anos
atrás um matemático de lá ganhou a
medalha fields que é o prêmio mais
importante da matemática
não sei se vocês já ouviram falar mas
tem a ver aqui com a minha palestra que
o prêmio niwano um belo dia o alfred
nobel que foi esse cara que deixou toda
a fortuna dele para o prêmio nobel
acordou e leu uma notícia uma notinha do
jornal dizendo que um mercador da morte
que era ele no caso tinha morrido
ele leu a notícia eu morri eu sou o
mercador da morte na verdade a notícia
está errada quem tinha morrido era o
irmão dele mas o que o tocou foi ele ver
que o legado que ele deixaria para o
mundo era como mercador da morte que ele
tinha criado é o comércio da dinamite
então ele resolve deixar toda o prêmio
dele é todo o dinheiro dele para a
criação do prêmio nobel ele criou o
prémio nobel da química o crime o prémio
nobel da literatura o prémio nobel é da
economia foi criado depois da medicina
mas não cria o prêmio nobel da
matemática você sabe por que ele não
criou o prêmio nobel da matemática que a
esposa dele o traía com o matemático bom
se meu sonho era ganhar o prêmio nobel
da matemática não está o prêmio nobel
não ia cena matemática que eu ia ser que
eu ia continuar o meu caminho então
estava lá no inpa né
enfim estudava igual um maluco mas eu
era o pior da sala com certeza eles até
me deram aquele chapeuzinho de burro
sabe eu tinha que desfila mentira é
e voltei para belo horizonte e falei bom
esse não é o meu caminho matemática
minha mãe meu caminho apesar de gostar
muito da matemática
resolvi fazer um mestrado e no mestrado
a mesma angústia o que eu vou fazer da
vida enfim tal resolvi fazer um mestrado
em lógica e filosofia nada a ver também
era apaixonado por um maluco chamado kit
gay deu que era um cara que provou que
na matemática existem aqui existem
afirmativas que são verdadeiras porém
demonstráveis também não conseguiu
demonstrar nada nem quero a verdade nem
que era falso
voltei para belo horizonte de novo e
comecei a fazer um mestrado em ciência
da computação
enfim maluco não sabe o que eu queria e
fim mas gostando muito de muitas coisas
e lendo muito e se esse ler era
constante
ao terminar o mestrado em computação
meio ainda sem saber o que queria da
vida mas sempre gostando mas eu queria
continuar continuar os meus estudos
e aí é essa minha paixão pela literatura
me levou a entrar de cabeça em um
escritor argentino chamado jorge luis
borges e jorge luis borges ele escreve
contos muito pequenos talvez de 23
páginas e nesses contos ele fala sobre o
universo fala sobre a cabala fala sobre
mística fala sobre filosofia e fala
sobre tudo e sobre a própria literatura
e ele fala um pouquinho sobre matemática
quando eu li o borges não falava bom tem
matemática que eu não sei porque tem
matemática na literatura
deixei aquilo guardadinho e conheci um
outro escritor um escritor chamado jorge
perreco jorge perreco tem uma vida muito
muito tocante a vida dele me tocou e ele
aos cinco anos de idade ele era uma
criança francesa que os pais foram
enviados para os campos de extermínio na
verdade a mãe morre em auschwitz e o pai
morre é no front de guerra e ele com
cinco anos de idade ele passa a vida
inteira tentando se recordar dos
momentos que ele teve com os pais e ele
começa a escrever com compulsivamente
tentando voltar nesse passado tentando
resgatar essas memórias e ele usa alguns
artifícios
ele escreve um livro que se chama lá
exportación à disposição em francês
significa o desaparecimento
o desaparecimento é ele conta a história
de desaparecimento de mortes terríveis
de atrocidade terríveis ele publica um
livro um livro de 340 páginas e francês
as pessoas começam a ler se tocam
bastante de repente descobrem que no
livro inteiro não tem a letra é para
quem sabe francesa a letra é a letra
mais freqüente do alfabeto e o que ele
fala ele fala se os nazistas me fizeram
viver sem meu pai minha mãe em francês
pé merck que são têm dois é de em cada
um eu tenho que ser capaz de escrever
uma literatura sem a letra mais
importante do alfabeto em francês a
letra é e aí ele começa a criar uma
literatura toda a matemática
bom eu tinha meu minha paixão pela
matemática pela computação e minha
paixão pela literatura que eu resolvi
fazer bom encontrei meu caminho vou
escrever uma tese de doutorado sobre
literatura e matemática e é isso que eu
faço eu escrevo uma tese de doutorado
sobre literatura e matemática me mudo
para frança escreva tese lá defendendo
um doutorado no brasil e na frança e por
acaso eu acho que ninguém entendeu o que
eu falei na tese eles me deram o prêmio
à melhor tese de doutorado do brasil
esse prêmio é muito legal você vai para
brasília o presidente da u
o prêmio mãos no caso o presidente
faltou mandou só o ministro da educação
que ele tava muito atribulado com outras
questões enfim mas no momento que eu
ganho o prémio da melhor tese de
literatura eu falo bom é isso meu
caminho acho que eu tô chegando lá eu
faço um pós-doutorado e depois eu sou
aceito como pesquisador visitante na
universidade harvard negócio bonito né o
rafa né fui lá fazer minhas pesquisas de
dia eu fazia minhas pesquisas oficiais
que era trabalhar com a questão do
testemunho do trauma da escrita
traumática e de noite eu escrevi o livro
de ficção o meu primeiro livro de ficção
é uma auto ficção que é uma auto ficção
basicamente isso aqui que eu tô fazendo
eu tô contando minha vida mas eu tô
engrandecendo estão mudando algumas
coisas eu escrevo esse meu livro
[Risadas]
eu escrevo esse meu livro de auto ficção
público esse livro né até até então só
minha mãe tinha lido é porque vocês vão
entender
minha mãe é mãe judia então ela sempre
está lá e aí eu escrevi esse livro
vários prêmios e de repente eu tô nos
estados unidos descobriu que esse livro
é finalista do maior prémio de
literatura do brasil
eu volto para a entrega do prêmio a
entrega do prêmio ao oscar nesta lá
sentado com aquela carinha é assim
olha se você ganhar você vai comemorar
mas se perder esta também tem que ficar
lindo né
e aí eu sei se eu cheguei lá que entrega
o governador do estado de são paulo e aí
esse livro cabo de recebe o prémio do
melhor livro de literatura do ano do
maior prémio de literatura
eu falei bom é isso que eu vou fazer da
vida né eu vou ser escritor vou escrever
sobre sobre a a minha vida sobre a
literatura sobre todos os momentos
só que tem um problema depois que você
escreve o seu primeiro livro de ficção e
este livro faz um grande sucesso todo
mundo fica querendo saber qual que vai
ser o seu próximo livro e eu estava lá
em casa pensando nessa sobre o que que
eu vou escrever qual vai ser o meu
próximo livro né
e aí enfim eu tenho está lá e que desde
resolvi escrever dois livros enfim sobre
temas diversos
o primeiro vocês me perdoem seu parecer
muito arrogante mas eu sou o maior
especialista do mundo inteiro vocês
nunca vão conhecer uma outra pessoa tão
especialista quanto eu no meu primeiro
livro é sobre brochadas se alguém quiser
dividir esse título amigo de vida na
hora
o problema é que ninguém quer dividir
comigo é esse título de seu maior
especialista embaixadas então escreva um
livro sobre brochadas né acho que a fota
bem ilustrativa e depois eu escrevo um
livro sobre a loucura
esses livros fazem grande sucesso enfim
é né tem muitas resenhas muitas críticas
e enfim eu descubra qual é o meu caminho
e lá no começo da minha palestra
hoje nessa tex o que eu falei para vocês
que meu sonho era criar a máquina do
tempo e ganhar o prémio nobel da
literatura eu descubro que é possível
criar essa máquina do tempo vocês
lembram lado aquele meu fora da silvinha
não é isso que eu fiz nessas auto
ficções que eu escrevi eu voltei aquele
momento e escrevi aquele momento como ea
memória como meus desejos me permitiram
então essa a na verdade eu sempre
procurei na engenharia na ciência da
computação na matemática esse sonho de
viajar no tempo e descobri que há na
literatura que a gente consegue viajar
no tempo né
vocês já devem estar se perguntando
bom eu tinha dois sonhos não é isso o
primeiro viajar no tempo e segundo ela
ganhar um prêmio nobel né
estão aparecendo minha mãe minha mãe
toda vez que eu consigo alguma coisa me
pergunte o próximo que tá aqui olha que
vem mais né
e essa aqui é a minha mãe todo ano
quando sai né quando a academia sueca é
divulga o prêmio nobel de literatura
minha mãe liga pra lá reclamando que não
ganhou o prêmio nobel de literatura
então eu resolvi paraná é pra resolver o
problema da minha mãe meu próximo livro
que já vai sair nas próximas semanas ele
se chama nobel e só eu recebendo o
prêmio nobel de literatura e fazendo o
meu discurso e ao invés de agradecer
todo mundo a gente faz aquele discurso
que todo mundo quer fazer mas ninguém
tem coragem de fazer
então é isso é o que eu queria falar pra
vocês enfim mesmo em sonhos loucos
lunáticos como esse a gente consegue
tornar algo no meu caso algo totalmente
impossível né pelo menos realizável
obrigado
[Aplausos]